All right, let's continue with our tour of
what was just an incredible, incredible weekend.
And I have something for you that is not just
amazing.
It's aso really smart.
South Carolina Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham, we don't like Lindsey.
He has a serious challenger this year.
It's Democrat Jamie Harrison.
And the polling looks like this really could
be a fight.
I'll tell you that in a moment.
Lindsey Graham also, aside from being a horrible
senator, has all sorts of possible corona
virus exposure, especially now that tons of
people at the White House and around Trump
have the virus.
So there was a debate over the weekend, Lindsey
Graham versus Jamie Harrison and Jamie Harrison
brought his own plexiglass barrier to put
around himself to protect him from Lindsey
Graham's germs.
This is the perfect combination of being hilarious
from like a visual optics perspective, but
also completely Ri's reasonable, given the
irresponsibility of the Republican Party and
the fact that the virus is spreading like
wildfire among Republicans who are close to
Donald Trump.
Chris Christie has tested positive.
Kellyanne Conway has tested positive and on
and on.
Lindsey Graham recently had contact with Republican
Senator Mike Lee.
Mike Lee is tested positive and was at that
Amy CONI Barrett super spreader event in the
White House last Saturday.
And so he Jamie Harrison bringing his own
plexiglass.
And that actually came up during the debate.
Check this out.
Here is Jamie Harrison.
It's not Judge Barrett, not the Supreme Court.
You know, this has impacted me personally.
My granddad, Gladys, passed away this July
in a nursing home by herself.
That is the story that so many Americans are
experiencing right now.
And part of why we're expensive.
No, we're not going to blame the president.
We shouldn't blame the president.
We shouldn't blame anybody for the inception
of this disease.
But where blame should come is how we handle
this disease.
Within that, we take it seriously.
You know, tonight I am taking it seriously.
That's why I put this plexiglass up, because,
you know, it's not just about me.
It's about the people in my life that I have
to take care of as well.
My two boys, my wife, my grandmother.
This debate was truly a brutal drubbing by
Jamie Harrison of Lindsey Graham.
And it's South Carolina.
Lindsey Graham may well get reelected.
But one of the met best moments for Jamie
Harrison.
And the worst for Lindsey Graham was when
Jamie Harrison went after Lindsay aggressively
for being a complete and total hypocrite on
the Supreme Court nomination of Amy CONI Barat.
Remember that Lindsey Graham back in 2016,
when they held off and suppressed and obstructed
the nomination of Merrick Garland, Lindsey
Graham said, hold me to it.
Even if this happens with Trump, we're not
doing it in the last year.
A little a little era.
And then now Lindsey Graham says Amy CONI
Barrett.
Yeah, let's do it.
Jamie Harrison calls him out and it's great.
It reminds me of playing Monopoly with my
son.
You changed the rules and he changes the rules
every time he gets, you know, Senator, you
said, use my words against me.
And you said it after the cabinet meetings
that before the cabinet hearings, after the
cabinet hearings and your words, your promise
was that no judicial nominee should be considered
or approved or what have you in the last year
of an election.
And you even named President Trump when you
said it.
And so this is my thing.
My grandfather always taught me.
He said, Jamie, a man is only as good as his
word.
Well, Senator, how good is your word?
When you made a promise to the American people
even more, you made a promise to the folks
in South Carolina that you wouldn't be doing
what you're doing right now.
And of course, Jamie Harrison is one hundred
percent correct.
Lindsey Graham is a huge hypocrite on this.
The Republicans haven't shown that they care
about hypocrisy.
But Lindsey is a massive hypocrite, and it's
just a really bad performance by Lindsey Graham.
He seemed rattled throughout a really funny
moment.
Lindsey Graham seems perplexed here.
He seems visually visibly perplexed about
where is the money coming from?
Who are these people donating money to Jamie
Harrison.
He simply can't conceive of the idea that
a lot of people, even in South Carolina, just
don't like him.
He thinks it's some kind of Democratic conspiracy.
It's like, no, when people don't like you
and they know you, they often donate to your
opponent.
That's it.
It was about ads and money.
Let's talk about money and politics.
Where the hell is all this money coming from?
What is it about?
South Carolina has attracted almost a hundred
million dollars into Jamie Harrison, Mr. Harrison's
coffers.
They hate me.
This is not about Mr. Harrison.
This is about liberals hating my guts because
I stood up for Cavenagh when they tried to
destroy his life.
This is about me helping Donald Trump.
The only good Republicans win, it tries to
undercut Trump.
I lost to President Trump when I ran for president.
If you don't remember me running for president,
it's not your fault.
Didn't last that long.
That is completely right.
It was crazy when Lindsey Graham went on that
lunatic rant defending Brett Kavanaugh.
People don't like him because of it.
Many people.
It has been ridiculous to watch Lindsey Graham
defend anything that Donald Trump does while
always trying to pretend that he's a one of
the reasonable Republicans.
Now, there is a real opportunity here for
Lindsey Graham to be defeated.
The entire point of this segment is to remind
you there is an alternative to Lindsey Graham
in South Carolina.
Yes, Jamie Harrison is not the most progressive
of progressive Democrats.
Yes.
He's been a South Carolina Democratic Party
insider for a while.
But we're talking about removing Lindsey Graham
here and possibly taking the Senate, which
would lead to actually getting things done
if indeed Joe Biden is able to defeat Donald
Trump.
The latest polls out of South Carolina.
You will notice we have polls from the last
six, seven months or even more up on the screen.
You'll notice this was not a close race early
in the year.
Lindsey Graham was up 13 and 17 in February.
But by July, Lindsey Graham was only up by
seven.
But the last four polls in this race from
August and September are three ties.
And Lindsey Graham ahead by only one.
This is South Carolina.
My friends and a Democratic challenger could
defeat a longtime incumbent Republican senator.
If you're looking at a race to get involved
in phone banking or in other ways, this is
a beautiful race.
And when when we talk about, you know, Trump's
not looking great in Georgia, Trump's not
looking great in Texas, but he'll he'll still
win.
But he may have to fight for it.
This is one where it really could just be
a win for Democrats.
It's not just the benefit of Lindsey will
have to spend money defending his seat.
That's great.
But we could actually go for a win here.
We should do it.
It could be the seat.
Any one of these close races could be the
seat that flips the Senate to Democrats.
And this is one I would recommend you get
involved in.
OK,